und herr maas das ist jetzt natürlich
für sie deswegen wichtig weil sie werden
in den kommenden jahren mit joe biden
und kanada harris viel zu tun haben
wie haben sie diese entscheidung der
amerikaner jetzt aufgenommen was waren
ihre ersten gedanken
diesmal haben wir das ja alle in den
letzten tag mit verfolgt und habe
mitgefiebert
es sind gute es ist jetzt auch mal zu
einem ende gekommen ist
ich glaube die beiden hat einen wirklich
historischen wahlsieg erreicht und zudem
gratulieren wir eben ganz herzlich und
wir freuen uns schon jetzt auf die
zusammenarbeit mit ihm und er hat im
übrigen auch in den letzten beiden tagen
wenn er gesprochen hat dinge gesagt auf
die wir so lange gewartet haben aus dem
weißen haus dass jemand sehr
verantwortungsvoll umgeht mit den
inneren problemen in den usa besser sich
aber auch den herausforderungen der welt
stellt und dass er mit den ab mit dem
partner in der trans unseren
transatlantischen bündnis also auch mit
europa hängt zusammen arbeiten will
also ich freue mich sehr auf die
zusammenarbeit mit dem team beiden herr
maas sie haben sich ja in den letzten
tagen in den vergangenen wochen
eigentlichen all den jahren immer sehr
zurückgehalten was kritik an donald
trump anging und auch in den letzten
stunden so zu sagen haben sie immer noch
abgewartet
jetzt können sie das erste mal wirklich
ehrlich sagen was sie von trump
eigentlich gehalten habe
wir waren selber ich gehöre nicht zu dem
soweit eine wahl entschieden ist
die den siegern immer zu jubeln und dann
beginnen auf den verlierern rumzuhacken
das ist eine schwierige zeit gewesen das
weiß jeder
die art und weise wie tom regiert also
wohl in den usa aber auch vor allen
dingen wie internationale politik
gemacht hat hat uns viele probleme
bereitet
und deshalb sind wir froh und freuen uns
dass mit einem neuen präsidenten zu tun
haben wäre wahrscheinlich die rolle der
vereinigten staaten international ganz
anders ausführen wird
und wir stehen dafür bereit es gibt
einiges wieder ins lot zu bringen im
transatlantischen verhältnis und ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass es mit joe
biden uns gut gelingen wird sie sagen
donald trump hat ihnen oder hat europa
probleme bereitet jetzt gab es einige
dinge die donald trump angesprochen hat
wo er durchaus
und hatte zum beispiel die zwei prozent
der militärausgaben was die nato angeht
und einige andere dinge warum was macht
sie gar nicht so sicher dass joe biden
jetzt der isi der einfache partner für
sie und die europäer wird
also easy wir gar nichts werden es gibt
doch bestimmte themen bei denen ich
glaube dass nicht viel verändert wird
das wird das thema 2 prozent seien aber
ich glaube der stil wie man miteinander
umgeht der wird ein ganz anderer werden
und er wird auch dafür sorgen dass wir
bei vielen unterschiedlichen
auffassungen die wir haben uns besser
am schluss auch zu kompromissen
zusammenfinden können und joe biden hat
ja ganz einfach auch in den reden die er
in den letzten beiden tagen gehalten hat
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen dass ist
jetzt darum geht der präsident aller
amerikaner zu sein ich habe das ist
zunächst mal die größte aufgabe es ist
völlig polarisierte land dieses völlig
gespaltene land wieder zusammenzuführen
da wird überhaupt der neue präsident
auch die zeit hat die möglichkeit hat
sich den wichtigen außenpolitischen
fragen zu stellen und da wird sich auch
nicht alles verändern also china wird
sicherlich auch für job weiten die
größte herausforderung sein und das ist
zb einer der punkte wo wir ähnliche
interessen haben weil wir auch die
gleichen werte haben mit den vereinigten
staaten
das könnte einer der punkte sein bei dem
man einen new deal im transatlantischen
verhältnis beginnt stück für stück
wieder realität werden zu lassen
die frage die sich viele amerikaner und
auch noch einige europäer gerade stellen
ist die frage räumt donald trump
eigentlich freiwillig dieses weiße haus
denn vor einer stunde kurz bevor das
ergebnis offiziell wurde hat er
geschrieben in versalien ein puzzle
action bei lot was glauben sie wird
donald trump jetzt tun und wird er das
weiße haus freiwillig verlassen
also ich habe auch in der vergangenheit
nie gewusst was donald trump tut und
deshalb kann ich noch nicht sagen wie
das jetzt weitergehen wird es wird
sicherlich in einigen staaten wo es
knapp war noch mal ausgezählt werden das
ist auch vollkommen in ordnung und
vollkommen normal
es wird auch gerichtsverfahren geben das
ist alles angekündigt die werden aber
auch zu einem ergebnis kommen ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass sie das
ergebnis der wahl der bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes bestätigen werden
und dann wird sicherlich auch sonnet
trump irgendwann verstehen dass die zeit
gekommen ist zu gehen und vielleicht
gibt es in seinem umfeld auch noch ein
paar vernünftige wie eben bei dieser
einsicht behilflich sind
in ihrer quarantäne sie sind immer noch
in sachen hund verlassen dort in
brandenburg kann man sagen
werden sie jetzt versuchen mit joe biden
mit seinem lager direkt von dort kontakt
aufzunehmen also ich muss noch ein
bisschen hier bleiben bedauerlicherweise
es gibt wirklich nichts schrecklicheres
für ein aus münster wenn der neue
amerikanische präsident gewählt wird
dass man hier in selbstisolation sitzt
aber natürlich werden wir sehr schnell
mit den kolleginnen kollegen in den usa
kontakt aufnehmen das wird alles noch
etwas dauern es geht auch darum paar
regeln zu beachten und auch zu
respektieren dass donald trump noch ein
paar monate bis zum 20 juni 20 januar
der präsident sein wird im übrigen mit
voller ausstattung und full power also
das ist eine zeit dem müssen auch noch
hinter uns bekommen
aber natürlich werden wir sehr schnell
den kontakt suchen mit denjenigen die in
der regierungsverantwortung übernehmen
und ich bin mir sicher und ich freue
mich sehr auf diese zusammenarbeit und
bin mir sicher dass es auch eine gute
werden würde freuen anfangen zu freuen
ich zumindest als jemanden münchen
aufgewachsen ist das womöglich die erste
große außenpolitische auftritt des neuen
us-präsidenten in münchen bei der
sicherheitskonferenz sein wird ich
jemals als möglicher würde mich sehr
darüber freuen können sie da vielleicht
ein gutes wörtchen eindringlingen und
bisschen lobbyarbeit dafür machen
also ich bin zwar kein münchner aber ich
glaube die sicherheitskonferenz in
münchen die ja wirklich ein event ist
von so grosser internationaler bedeutung
der werden wenn das krone erlaubt
hoffentlich sicherlich ganz viele
hinkommen zu beginn des nächsten jahres
und natürlich würden wir sehr darüber
freuen wenn joe biden selbst da wäre
oder möglicherweise auch kämmerer harris
auf jeden fall diejenigen die dann im
kabinett schon verantwortung übernommen
haben das ist eine gute möglichkeit
nicht nur mit uns in deutschland sondern
mit vielen internationalen partnern zu
reden und darüber zu sprechen wie es
weitergehen kann auch zu hören wie der
plan ist in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik der neuen
amerikanischen regierung also das würde
uns alle
freue mich auch wenn der präsident oder
zumindest die vize-präsidentin da sein
werden sicherlich sind alle ganz
gespannt was uns jetzt aus washington in
der welt erwartet freude außenminister
ist es nicht auch im moment rückblickend
ein bisschen ja auch dem scheidenden
us-präsidenten zumindest respekt zu
zollen für die eine oder andere sache
die er durch seine unkonventionelle art
offenbar angestoßen hatte sie haben
selber china erwähnt also der der ton
von cramm gegenüber tina baier erstmals
wirklich sehr konfrontativen das hat uns
alle auch so ein bisschen aufgeregt dann
dann die friedensverträge im in israel
und den arabischen staaten wie niemand
so erwartet hätte also ist es nicht auch
im moment immer ein bisschen respekt zu
zollen und bei aller freude über den
neuen präsidenten
also ich glaube dass das eine das andere
nicht ausschließt ich bin übrigens
jemand der auffassung ist dass man immer
menschen anderen mit respekt
gegenübertreten muss im übrigen auch
wenn man sie nicht verstehen und das
werden wir auch tun und das werde ich
auch tun ich habe in dem studio in dem
sie sitzen vor kurzem selber mal darauf
hingewiesen dass das was mit blick auf
den nahost friedensprozess mit blickt er
auch die aufnahme diplomatischer
beziehungen zwischen israel und den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten zum
beispiel angestoßen worden ist für
bewegung gesorgt hat gebe dort vorher
jahrzehnte nicht wagen und auch die
verhandlungen der amerikanischen
regierung mit den taliban hat dazu
geführt dass jetzt die afghanische
regierung und die taliban dort an einem
tisch sitzen um über einen
friedensvertrag zu warnen also bin der
allerletzte der so was jetzt leugnen
würde und ich glaube es die art und
weise wie soweit und spricht in den
letzten beiden tagen mit viel respekt
sehr verantwortungsvoll das ist
eigentlich das was man von einem
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
erwartet aber sie haben vollkommen recht
auch scheidenden präsidenten hat man
respekt entgegenzubringen gegenüber
allen den fall so begegnet in seinem
leben
und auch wenn man manchmal der
auffassung sein könnte dass derjenige
den wir gerne respekt entgegen
entgegenbringen
mit dem bag gegenüber anderen manchmal
sehr sparsam umgegangen ist
werden sie werden sich jetzt in den
nächsten tagen auch was das was sie
nämlich auch in unserer sendung gesagt
haben was ich eigentlich fahren werden
mit unserer in ihrer sendung haben sie
auch etwas gesagt was hinsichtlich china
was sehr sehr deutlich wahr sie haben
ganz klar gesagt dass china die große
bedrohung sozusagen für die stabilität
dieser welt sie haben unglaublich klare
worte auch zu hongkong gefunden
ich habe freunde in taiwan die übrigens
sehr besorgt sind und angst davor haben
als nächste quali geschluckt zu werden
glauben sie dass sie dem präsidenten
beiden einen verbündeten haben was ein
café ist ein hartes auftreten gegenüber
china an betritt das glaube ich glaube
dass in der amerikanischen politik
gegenüber stehen dass ich so viel nicht
verändern wird es gibt auch keine große
unterschiede zwischen den demokraten und
den republikanern mit blick auf china
china ist die große herausforderung
übrigen nicht nur für die vereinigten
staaten
sie ist auch für uns europäer eine große
herausforderung in china ist ein
wir nennen das ein systemischer rivale
und ich glaube ja wir sind in den
letzten in den letzten monaten sehr
augsburg gewesen gegenüber der
chinesischen führung mit blick auf das
was in hongkong geschehen ist mit blick
auf die figuren und die dortigen
menschenrechtsverletzungen oder auch
sicherheitsfragen im südchinesischen
meer
und deshalb ist es ja so wichtig dass
die europäer und die amerikaner in
solchen fragen wo wir eigentlich die
gleiche auffassung haben weil wir die
gleichen werte haben endlich wieder
intensiver zusammenarbeit und deshalb
könnte china einer der ersten punkte
sein wo wir in deutschland oder wir als
europäer mit den amerikanern wieder
wieder näher zusammenrücken und das was
wir zu sagen haben und das was wir
wollen zusammen sagen dann ist es im
übrigen auch viel wirkungsvoller
gegenüber peking
herr maas bevor wir sie jetzt
verabschieden doch noch eine allerletzte
frage wie muss man sich das jetzt
vorstellen bei ihnen in brandenburg
machen sie da jetzt die nacht durch und
telefonieren mit allen europäischen
regierungschefs um eine strategie zu
entwickeln
oder ist es nicht mehr arbeit als vorher
die situation jetzt also ähnlichen das
haben wir natürlich vorher auch schon
miteinander gesprochen
den einfall und für den anderen fall wie
wir uns verhalten und deshalb glaube ich
dass wir diese arbeit eigentlich nur
fortsetzen müssen ich gestellt das
selber fest bei all denen die in den
letzten minuten bei mir angerufen oder
haben oder wenn mir geschrieben haben
aus der ganzen welt
es ist sowas wie ein großes aufatmen
dass durch die internationale politik
gibt da gibt es viel freude auch viel
erwartung hoffentlich ist die eine oder
andere überraschung nicht etwa erwartung
nicht etwas überzogen
aber wir stehen bereit um das
transatlantische verhältnis wieder zu
reparieren und wird auch oder mann zu
bringen dass wir nicht nur wie in
deutschland sondern da gibt es ganz ganz
viele in europa mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren